imagina que estás resolviendo un sistema
de dos ecuaciones lineales con dos
incógnitas ya has encontrado más de una
solución que satisfaga el sistema cuál
de las siguientes afirmaciones es verdad
y bueno antes de leer estas afirmaciones
que por cierto están bien entretenidas
lo que quiero ver es de una forma
gráfica qué está pasando con este
problema así que déjame dibujar te aquí
mis dos ejes este va a ser un eje del
asia es este de aquí va a ser mi eje de
las equis y bueno si estamos hablando
acerca de dos ecuaciones lineales de una
manera gráfica estamos hablando de dos
rectas por lo tanto podemos estar en
tres posibles escenarios que estas dos
rectas nunca se interceptan es decir voy
a dibujar aquí dos rectas paralelas que
cada una de estas ecuaciones lineales me
represente una recta y estas rectas
nunca se interceptan como este caso de
aquí ahora bien en este caso de aquí no
tenemos solución porque estas dos rectas
no se intersectan y date cuenta que en
este problema no podemos estar en este
caso porque nos dicen que hemos
encontrado más
solución entonces este caso no es y
entonces vamos a fijarnos en nuestro
segundo caso nuestro segundo caso es que
tuviéramos dos rectas que se
interceptaran en un solo punto en este
punto sería la solución de mi sistema
ahora date cuenta que las líneas son un
poco rígidas y por lo tanto solamente se
interceptan aquí en este punto y como
solamente tenemos una intersección mi
solución es única y por lo tanto tampoco
podría ser esta nuestra respuesta porque
el problema nos dice que hemos
encontrado más de una solución así que
nuestro tercer caso es que tuviéramos la
misma recta que mis dos rectas fueran la
misma recta en cuyo caso cada uno de los
puntos sería solución de este sistema no
solamente tendríamos dos soluciones
tendríamos una infinidad de soluciones
porque estas rectas se intersectan en
cada uno de sus puntos y entonces como
el problema nos dice que hemos
encontrado más de una solución quiere
decir que estamos en este caso que por
cierto date cuenta que es el inciso si
existe una infinidad más de soluciones
del sistema
este inciso